in this video i want to do a couple more
word problems dealing with graphs of
lines so here we have a gym is offering
a deal to new members customers can sign
up by paying a registration fee of 200
so they pay hundred dollars and then a
monthly fee of thirty nine dollars
thirty nine dollars
per
month this is registration
registration
how much will this membership cost a
member by the end of the year so let's
figure out an equation that determines
how much total we will pay
so what we pay so let's p is equal to
the amount that we're going to pay in
total for our membership so no matter
how many months we use the gym just to
start using the gym we have to pay 200
in registration so we're going to have
to pay 200 i'll just write everything
we'll assume is in dollars so i'll write
200
and then we're going to have to pay 39
for every month we're there so then
we're going to take
the number of months we're there and
multiply that times
39. notice if we stay there one month
we'll have to pay one month times thirty
nine dollars and we would have already
paid the two hundred dollar registration
fee so it'll be two hundred and thirty
nine dollars if we stay two months we
pay the two hundred dollar registration
fee and then we pay 39 times two months
which is what like 78 or something so
it'd be 278 dollars
so just to tie this all together with
linear equations and graphs of them
let's graph this relation
and remember the graph of a line can be
y is equal to mx plus b that's one of
the forms so to put this line in this
form or this equation in this form we
can just rearrange the 39m and the 200
and you get
p
p
is equal to 39
m
plus 200. so what's the slope and what's
the y-intercept and you might get
confused hey there's an x there and a y
but now you're doing with ps and m's
just remember this is the independent
variable
that is independent
independent
pendant and this is the dependent
variable here this is the independent
variable how many months you pick a
number of months and i'll tell you what
the total cost of your membership is
going to be so it's the same thing this
is like the x right there and this is
like the y just like that
and so just using our pattern match
this right here is the
we could say it's the vertical intercept
or the p intercept or the well you know
i'm tempted to call it the y intercept
but we're really intersecting the p axis
instead of the y axis there and this
right here is our slope
so let's graph this
function and i won't do it too
accurately i just want to do a hand
drawn graph just to give you an idea we
could just stay in the first quadrant
we're not going to state negative months
and the gym is never going to pay us
money
so right off the bat we're going to have
to pay the gym 200
we're going to have to pay the gym
just like that
two hundred dollars for zero months then
for every month we're going to spend an
extra 39
so the slope is 39 so that's they say
this is one month right there that's
this is in months
this is months and then this axis is
price
the p-axis so this is as i said this is
like the p-intercept or the y-intercept
so after one month how much are we going
to pay well our slope is 39 so if we
move one month forward we're going to go
up by 39 so this will right here that
will be
239 and if we go another month
if we go another month it'll be 278.
this is kind of a weird labeling of an
axis but i think you get the idea so the
graph of how much it'll cost us per
month will look something
it will look something like this and so
they say how much will a membership cost
by the end of the year 12 months so we
would have to go 2
3 all the way out to 12 months which
might be here so our graph is going to
be out here someplace but we could just
figure it out algebraically
at the end of the year we will m will be
equal to 12. when m is equal to 12 how
much is our membership the price of our
membership is going to be our 200
membership fee plus 39 times the number
of months times 12 and what's 39 times
12 39 times 12 2 times nine is
seven is eighteen two times three is six
plus one is seventy i have a zero one
times nine is nine one times three we
wanna ignore this one times three is
three
so we have 8
7 plus 9 is 16
1 plus 3 is 4. so this right here so the
price of our membership is 200 plus 39
times 12 which is
468 dollars so it's equal to 668 dollars
at the end of our year so if you went
all the way up to 12 you'd have to plot
668 someplace here on our line if we
just kept
going out there let's do one more of
these
bobby and petra are running a lemonade
stand and they charge
45 cents for each glass of lemonade 45
cents
per glass
45 cents per glass of lemonade in order
to break even they must make 25 dollars
they must make 25 how many glasses of
lemonade must they sell to break even so
let's
let's let me just do it with y and x y
is equal to the amount they make amount
they make
and they not max the amount they
make
and let x is equal to the number
of
glasses
they sell
they sell so what is y as a function of
x
so y is equal to
well for every glass they sell they get
45 cents so it's equal to
45 cents
times the number of glasses right and
there's not any kind of like minimum fee
that they need to charge or they don't
say any kind of minimum cost that they
have to spend to run this place so how
much
in order to break even for each glass of
lemonade
they need to make 25 dollars so in order
to make break even they must make 25
dollars so how many glasses of lemonade
do they need to sell so that this thing
needs y needs to be equal to 25 dollars
so how many glasses do you need to sell
well you just set this equation you say
point zero five oh sorry point zero .04
or
0.45 x
has to be equal to 25
has to be equal to 25 we can divide both
sides by 0.45
0.45
0.45
on the left-hand side you're just left
with an x you get x is equal to
what is 25
what is
25 divided by 0.45
is equal to
so at 50
they would have to sell exactly 55.55
glasses or 5 6 if i round so 55.5
repeating glasses but you can't sell
half a glass or assuming you can't have
sell half a glass so the answer that
they must sell 56
glasses because you can't sell half a
glass i'm assuming so they need to sell
56 glasses to break even and just to
graph this
once again we'll hang out in the first
quadrant because everything is going to
be positive
every glass they make 45 cents
so let's say that they sell so this is
the number of glasses x this is how much
they make let me go by and we go by
increments of oh i don't know let me go
by increments of 5
5
10
15
20
25 actually i need to go buy even larger
increments to get to the point that
we're talking about let me go by
increments of 10 10
20
30
40
50
60. so that's the number of glasses and
when they sell zero glasses they make
zero dollars that's their y-intercept
it's at y is equal to zero then when
they sell ten glasses they make four
dollars fifty so this is 450
this is nine
actually let me just do it like this
let me just let me just mark
only the
only the
nine dollar the multiples of nine
so let's say 9
18
27
35
and when they sell 10 glasses they're
going to make 4.50 10 times 0.45 so
that's right there
20 glasses are going to make nine
dollars
we could keep going there 40 glasses are
going to make 18
you see their slope when you move 10
you're going to have to go up 450. so
this graph is going to look something
like that should be a straight line and
then if you want to see their break even
the break even has to be 25 dollars
which is right
which is right about here
25
the break even is 25 dollars right
around there
let me do a little bit
let me draw the line a little bit better
than that
so the line is going to look like this
and the break even is 25
right there
you see
that they have to sell
about 56 glasses and obviously the way i
drew this isn't a super neatly drawn
graph but hopefully it gives you the
general idea